all right
over there
i can go
yes
oh
yes
you have a shower
uh
[Music]
a body
thank you
okay
i keep my eyes open
bye
yes
he came back
i wonder out there
i guess she came in here
i was wondering
oh
charles
all
hello
um
um
right over here
hey today
right
um
correct
um
like the empty space between guild and
uh
years ago
that's what
myself
we're in the process
so
okay
two minute warning on the press briefing
two minute warning on the press briefing
thank you
all right
i'm very nervous
thank you
hi everyone well we have another special
guest with us here today
joining us today is ann neuberger a
deputy national security advisor for
cyber
and emerging technology i told her
that's quite a title well deserved
ann was previously the national security
agency's director of cyber security
where she led nsa's cyber security
mission prior to that role she led nsa's
election security effort and served as
assistant deputy director of nsa's
operations directorate overseeing
foreign intelligence and cyber security
operations
she also previously served as nsa's
first chief risk officer
as director of nsa's commercial solution
center as director of enduring security
framework cyber security public private
partnership
as the navy's deputy chief management
officer and as a white house fellow
uh she is going to provide all of you an
update on the administration's work
related to solar
winds and she's willing to take a couple
of questions as usual i will play the
bad cop come on over and when you're
ready
good afternoon it's great to be here
with you today so i'll give an update
across our solarwinds work
what happened how did it happen and what
are we doing about it
so first what happened hackers launched
a broad and indiscriminate effort
to compromise the network management
software used by both government and the
private sector
the intelligence community is looking at
who is responsible
until that study is complete i'll use
the language we previously used which
was to say
an advanced persistent threat actor
likely of russian origin
was responsible as of today
nine federal agencies and about a
hundred private sector companies were
compromised
as you know roughly eighteen thousand
entities downloaded the malicious update
so the scale of potential access far
exceeded the number of known compromises
many of the private sector compromises
are technology companies
including networks of companies whose
products could be used to launch
additional intrusions
so why does this matter why is this
significant the techniques that were
used
lead us to believe that any files or
emails on
a compromise network were likely to be
compromised the scope and scale of our
investigation is underway and we look
forward to providing you future updates
in in the future so how did this happen
there's two parts to that them and us
the actor was a sophisticated advanced
persistent threat
advance because the level of knowledge
they showed about the technology
and the way they compromised it truly
was sophisticated
persistent they focused on the identity
part of the network which is the hardest
to clean up
and threat the scope and scale to
networks to information
makes this more than an isolated case of
espionage
and then us there's a lack of domestic
visibility
so as a country we choose to have both
privacy and security
so the intelligence community largely
has no visibility into private sector
networks
the hackers launched the hack from
inside the united states
which further made it difficult for the
us government to observe their activity
even within federal networks a culture
and
authorities inhibit visibility which is
something we need to address
i want to take a moment to thank the
public and private sector network
defenders who've been working
very hard to find and expel these
adversaries from both government and
private sector networks
so finally and most significantly what
are we going to do about it
three things first finding and expelling
the adversary
second building back better to modernize
federal defenses
and reduce the risk of this happening
again and finally potential response
options
to the perpetrators so first finding and
expelling the adversary
we're coordinating the interagency
response from the national security
council
i was on the hill last week at hill
discussions this week and will be on the
hill
next week as well we're working closely
with daily conversations
with our private sector partners they
have visibility and technology
that is key to understanding the scope
and scale of compromise
there are legal barriers and
disincentives to the private sector
sharing information with the government
that is something we need to overcome
and then finally
this is challenging this is a
sophisticated actor who did their best
to hide their tracks
we believe it took them months to plan
and execute this compromise
it'll take us some time to uncover this
layer
by layer second building back better to
modernize federal defenses we are
absolutely committed to reducing the
risk this happens again
if you can't see a network you can't
defend a network and federal networks
cybersecurity
need investment and more of an
integrated approach to detect and block
such threats we're also working
on close to about a dozen things likely
eight will pass
it'll be part of an upcoming executive
action to address
the gaps we've identified it in our
review of this incident
and finally in terms of response to the
perpetrator
discussions are underway i know some of
you will want to know what kind of
options are being contemplated
what i will share with you is how i
frame this in my own mind
this isn't the only case of malicious
cyber activity of likely russian origin
either for us or for our allies and
partners so as we contemplate future
response options we're considering
holistically
what those activities were i look
forward to coming back
and keeping you posted as we continue
identifying the scope and scale and
begin and continue our execution and
thank you so much for your time
do you have any questions
thanks again for doing this just to 30
000 footage you have a time frame in
terms of how long this investigation
will take and then
obviously you're not going to lay out
specific details of what you will do in
response but if you have a timeline on
the response as well as a tag to
whenever the investigation ends
or how are you guys thinking through
that so most importantly
as we're looking at what caused the
solar winds we're also executing the
three things i talked about we're
working to expel the adversary
we're working to build those networks
and improve the cyber security of
federal networks
and we're also carefully thinking
through how we respond so the
investigation as i noted because of the
sophistication
it's taking us layer by layer but we're
working at the same pace to ensure we
lock down networks and really think
through
how to ensure this doesn't happen again
in the future do you have a timeline i
understand it's complicated but
how long it would take to go layer by
layer and really understand the
gravitational scope
i think we're estimating several months
but as i said
literally you know day by day hour by
hour
we're making progress in understanding
okay as you look at the scope and the
scale of this
do you have a price tag or a sense of a
price tag it could begin to account
the total cost of damage to the us
government from this compromise
it's a really interesting question
there's two parts right one is it's
really
highlighted the investments we need to
make in cyber security to have the
visibility to block these attacks in the
future
and then the second is the scale of the
information that was potentially
compromised
and the impact of how that information
could be used in the hands of a
malicious actor
so it's there's certainly a cost with
regard to dollars it's also a cost with
regard to national security
and we're bounding and understanding
both and there's been some discussion
that entire networks could have to be
scrapped and rebuilt essentially from
the ground up
i know you know you don't get the
specifics of a timeline but are we
talking about
years potentially to try and secure some
of these networks going forward
we certainly don't have years it's wise
when planning in cyber security to
consider the worst case particularly
when you're dealing
with such a sophisticated attacker in
that way
so we know we don't have years and the
remediation the fix and cleanup work is
underway already
and we'll be doing it in a careful way
to ensure that we lock down layer by
layer but we know it's going to be a lot
shorter than that
and what have we specifically learned
about this attack in terms of kind of
the data that was stolen
and you know agencies that were impacted
we know the number
but what kind of communications were
really impacted by this hack
good question one of the things we've
done from the white house is do a
coordinated set of questions to assess
that
and pull that piece together it varies
agency by agency
and certainly there is national security
impact and that is what we're looking to
consider
both how we manage the risk of that and
how we address it for the future
and do we have any understanding of kind
of the motive that that drove this uh
this attack i mean based on the
assessment that you've had
what what were the hackers really trying
to go after i mean any particular agency
out of the nine that you that you found
that you were going after certainly as
we look at the agencies
there are a number of those of high
foreign intelligence interest
to a foreign government so we know that
was certainly one goal
but as i noted earlier when there is a
compromise of this scope and scale
both across government and across the
u.s technology sector to lead to
follow-on intrusions
it is more than a single incident of
espionage
it's fundamentally of concern for the
ability for this to become disruptive
oh good oh good you had your hand right
since it's involved both uh government
agencies in the private sector as well
how much are you able to share with the
private sector as far as
um you know what may have been
compromised on their end and what they
can do maybe to prevent this from
happening again
in the u.s government in the united
states the way we're structured
public-private partnership
has to be a core part of national cyber
defense so there's active sharing going
on in both directions
government sharing its insights with
private sector entities both who have
been compromised and those who have
broader visibility
and private sector entities sharing
their insights to ensure we can together
scope and scale what occurred one more
question what
um do you believe you'll find additional
u.s agencies and private companies that
have been hacked or is it gonna
is this the final number um and have you
ruled out data deletion or manipulation
so due to the sophistication of the
techniques that were used
we believe we're in the beginning stages
of understanding the scope and scale and
we may find
additional compromises particularly
given the technology companies that were
compromised
and no we have not ruled out potential
additional activity but we're very
focused on
carefully taking this step by step to
understand the broad implications
thank you anne so much and we hope to
have you back
any time thank you all thank you
okay just a couple of additional updates
for all of you uh today
president biden will meet with labor
leaders to thank them for their role
representing workers and supporting a
strong
american middle class and to discuss the
importance of passing the american
rescue plan
which will not only help contain the
pandemic and deliver immediate economic
relief but will also
create jobs including good union jobs
today our coveted response team also
announced critical steps to expand
testing in the united states
a critical piece of turning the type the
tide of the pandemic and protecting our
public health
today they have announced that the
federal government will invest
1.6 billion dollars already allocated
funds
uh but in three areas and this includes
650 million to support
testing in schools and underserved
communities
hhs will use these funds to create
regional coordinating centers that will
partner with labs to leverage their
underutilized testing capacity
these coordinating centers will help
match lab capacity with demand from
schools congregate settings
like homeless shelter shelters or other
underserved populations
almost 200 million dollars will go to
increase genomic sequencing
the surge in funding will result in a
three-fold increase in the cdc's genomic
sequencing capacity
to get us to 25 000 samples a week this
will help us identify variants
sooner which is obviously important and
pivotal at this point in time
and 815 million dollars will go to
manufacture critical testing supplies on
things like
filter uh pipette tips nitrocellulose
used in
antigen tests and specialized injection
molded plastics needed to house
testing regents these are critical steps
to address vital issues this funding and
these efforts are far from what is
necessary it simply provides a bridge
to the funding that is in in the
american
rescue plan which will help us
get more shots into the arms of
americans i also have an update on the
winter storms in texas which i know is
of great interest to many of you
our team and fema continue to monitor
the situation in texas
as well as other states in the storm's
path that might be impacted
we remain in close contact with states
across the affected area to ensure
any federal support requirements are met
feed
by generators to texas and is preparing
to move
diesel into the state to ensure the
continued availability of backup power
which of course is a major issue on the
ground to key critical infrastructure
including communications hospitals and
water
fema is also supplying texas with water
and blankets at their requests
we're preparing to quickly process
requests from other states for emergency
assistance that's how the process
typically works
and we urge people in the affected
states to of course listen to their
emergency management officials
final updates ahead of the meeting this
afternoon the president is taking
several steps to expand high quality
registered apprenticeships to reward
work rebuild the middle class and
connect a diverse workforce
to family supporting living wage jobs
specifically today he is
endorsing congressman scott's national
apprenticeship act
which the house estimates will create
nearly one million
new apprenticeship opportunities and
help ensure women and workers of color
benefit he's reinstating the
long-standing national advisory
committee on apprenticeships
which will help will bring the voice of
unions employers community colleges and
other institutions to expanding
and improving the registered
apprenticeship programs and that he is
signing an executive order
that reverses trump's executive order
former president trump's executive order
which spurred the creation of industry
recognized apprenticeship programs
programs lack quality standards and
threatened to undermine the registered
apprenticeship programs
that have been the pathway to middle
class for decades i said that was the
last
one more thing also today the president
nominated jennifer abruzzo
as general counsel of the national labor
relations board
and many of you have been following the
change over of leadership there
having spent more than 20 years working
for the nlrb
abruzzo will bring with her deep
experience and knowledge of the nlrb's
role
and will be an important partner in
building a strong and more resilient and
more inclusive
economy that delivers every american a
fair return for their work
with that a couple things at the top go
ahead thanks uh i had a couple of
questions
uh sort of follow-ups from yesterday and
this morning uh on two different issues
first on getting the five days a week
school the vice president this morning i
believe said it's a priority to get
vaccinations
for teachers um can you get to five days
a week without vaccinations does the
president believe that teachers need to
be
vaccinated uh before they go back to
school
uh no neither the president nor the vice
president
believe that um that it should be it is
a requirement
uh this the cdc guidelines included
a range of mitigation steps including
vaccinations as recommendations but the
mitigation steps also included
uh steps like social distancing the need
for
smaller class sizes the need for
sanitation
so these are this was one of several
steps recommended in the cdc guidelines
now at the same time the president and
the vice president both believe that
t-shirts should be prioritized and as
you all know
that's up to states to determine there
are federal recommendations about half
of the country half
about half of the states in the country
have prioritized teachers
and they both feel that's important
including child health care workers
um and they both feel that that's
something that is impacting
working women and moms who are trying to
go back to work and trying to make sure
that their kids have the attention and
child care they need so
it's not a requirement to reopen schools
but they believe that teachers should be
prioritized
on the impact particularly women you
just mentioned
also the idea of getting to that seven
million number that the president talked
about
yesterday that if you pass the plan you
can get
all the estimates that say you can get
seven million jobs back this year
yeah can you do that without getting
back to five days of school how do women
go back to work
without having their kids full time in
school
well i will say one of the reasons that
the president has
put 130 billion dollars of funding in
his american rescue plan is because
he knows that schools across the country
need funding to
satisfy some of the mitigation steps
that are recommended in the cdc
guidelines
i talked with him about this this
morning and his concern as you have
raised that
uh this is deeply impacting women we're
seeing that statistically with every
week and every month of
jobs numbers we've seen it anecdotally
and uh his concern
is about the impact of course on working
women today but also on how it will
uh it will bring us back uh in the years
ahead because if there are fewer women
who are in the workplace there are fewer
women climbing the corporate ladder
there are fewer women who are getting
law degrees
getting doctorates and that has a
long-term impact so
you're right that or i should say what
i'm taking from your question is
you know can we can we get this done if
we don't have funding if we don't have
the
different components when he announced
his goal of opening the majority of
schools
he made clear we need to have funding
because most many schools will tell you
across the country
they were waiting for the cdc guidelines
they want to know how to do it safely
but
they don't have they need the funding to
hire more teachers they need more bus
drivers they need
uh the ability to implement the
mitigation steps that are going to work
for their school districts
that's one last thing uh from last night
um
president biden said no one should go to
jail for a drug offense
what did he mean by that uh well anyone
who uh
had the pleasure of journeying around
the country with him before kovid and
and then during
during kobe when it was doing when it
was happening uh remotely
he talked again and again on the
campaign trail about
eliminating mandatory minimums and
making sure that people suffering from
addiction
aren't incarcerated for drug use alone
but instead are sent
to treatment that's reflected in the
plan he put forward
on the campaign and that's his goal as
president and of course we're four weeks
in so there's a lot more policy work to
be done uh but
that is a that is a commitment and a
policy proposal or policy uh
commitment he talked about on the
campaign trail um
go ahead hi thank you um just a couple
follow-ups again from last night
sure um the president mentioned um that
you know china will face repercussions
uh for human rights abuses against
uyghurs and
in hong kong and taiwan etc um
what did he specifically mean by
repercussions i mean
is is the white house considering
sanctions or
uh even under trump there were a lot of
chinese companies that were added to a
economic blacklist is that likely to
continue as you
evaluate your options how are you
thinking in terms of
replication well what the president the
full context of his comments was also
about how during his conversation with
president xi
he uh talked about the values of the
united states and that
the fact is is that even when you are uh
communicating with another world leader
and you're having a tough conversation
we can't our values and our um and our
priorities
uh whether it's human rights as it
relates to the uyghurs
and what they have suffered through or
the freedom of press or media they can't
take a back seat and so
the context of his comments were that
those are issues he's going to continue
to raise
as it relates to our policy toward china
we are not in a rush we are focused on
uh communicating and working with our
partners and allies around the world
the president has had a number of
conversations as you know with europeans
uh he will continue uh conversations
with world leaders
in the weeks ahead but uh beyond that uh
there's an ongoing policy process and i
don't have anything uh to preview for
you today so so
you know just in terms of the existing
restrictions
that were put under the previous
administration are they likely to
continue as you sort of you know
take your time and sort of have a
measured response to this
well i wouldn't i didn't call it a
measured response what i conveyed was
that
uh our process is to ensure that we are
strengthening our economy at home we can
we want to come to our
approach to china to that relationship
from a position of strength
uh that is something the president is
national security team are doing
uh he is also going to communicate we
see our relationship with
china as one focused around competition
uh he's also going to focus on
working with our partners and allies
around the world in europe and in asia i
don't have anything to preview for you
in terms of additional policy steps
other than to convey for you broadly
that's our approach and when he was
answering the question at the town hall
he was reiterating his view that as
president and his commitment i should
say
that he is not going to miss an
opportunity to restate his values and
our values as a country
go ahead oh i can come back to you but
go ahead on the issue of teachers
you're making it clear that a
vaccination isn't a must as the cdc
recommends but that you hope that states
prioritize this
is this administration sharing that
message with teachers has the president
been reiterating that with governors
urging them
to put teachers at the front of the line
the president uh
absolutely it's something he said at a
nationally televised town hall meeting
last night and something that
uh he will continue to communicate uh at
every opportunity and
uh you know i think what i was conveying
just for full clarity is that
it's a recommendation it's a number one
of many mitigation steps but the cdc
guidelines are guidelines they're not
requirements uh but at the same time
the president and the vice president
believe that teachers should be
prioritized and in many states they
already are
but you do agree with the guidelines you
do agree with the cdc recommendation
that
vaccinations are not a must for teachers
that it is one of
correct that is one of mitigation and a
number of mitigation steps that should
be taken
by schools to keep things safe now it's
important to also reiterate um and when
i talked to the president this morning
he conveyed this again
that we need money these school
districts need money
to deliver on these guidelines and when
his secretary of education is
confirmed hopefully next week i'll knock
on some wood then he will be leading
this effort this will be his number one
priority is working with these school
districts
uh to safely reopen as quickly as
possible the timeline for widespread
vaccine availability keeps getting
pushed back originally it seemed we were
eyeing
sometime in the spring now the president
last night's at the end of july
so when do we expect that there will be
enough doses for everyone who wants a
vaccine to be able to get one
well the president actually now i know
we've been putting out a lot of covet
news i realize that almost every day
the president actually announced last
week or we announced last week that he
would be purchasing
uh that the federal government would be
purchasing enough doses
to vaccinate 300 million americans so he
reiterated that
last night we will get the last shipment
of those doses the end of july
by the end of may we will have about 400
million doses
so at that point once we have 400
million doses
there will certainly be a larger swath
of people who will be eligible who will
be able to get access to vaccine but in
terms of
when every american who wants a vaccine
can get a vaccine we will have enough
doses by the end of july and those have
already been ordered from pfizer and
moderna
and just one more question on the
question of when we get some semblance
of normalcy that timeline also seems to
be shifting dr fauci had said a sense of
normalcy maybe in the fall
that's when you might be able to go to
theaters go to sporting events still
with mass of course
now it seems that's being slid to early
next year the president said maybe
around christmas
what's going on here when do we think we
will get back to some
taste of normalcy well this is the
question as i'm sure is the case for all
of you that every neighbor
every friend every family member asks
at least me in the street when i'm
walking my dog in the morning um
we want to be straight with the american
public though it is we are not in a
place where we can predict
exactly when everybody will feel normal
again and it has there are
a number of reasons one is even though
we will have
enough doses for every person in this
country as you all know because we've
talked about it in here
vaccine hesitancy remains a challenge uh
we need to ensure that that everybody
who
can get a dose is getting a dose we all
will also need to be masking for some
time
we will also need to be still taking
social distancing measures so
uh you know there there's of course is
an understandable question and i think
the president uh wants things to return
to normal as we all do uh but we
uh we we don't know at this point what
that timeline is going to look like
glenville thanks jeff um i'll commit to
it clarify a couple things on
school funding are the goals as they're
laid out right now for reopening
entirely contingent on having the 130
billion dollars or those goals
to reopen a majority of schools by the
end of 100 days
based on not having that money and that
money will only serve to
turbo charge things well when the
president announced his goal
of reopening the majority of schools in
100 days he conveyed
that money was a pivotal part of that
and it is
and it is not it is up to of course
local school districts to determine
which mitigation steps they will take um
it is up to them
to uh to determine how they will use
accessible funds uh but that funding is
needed by school districts across the
country and
i think will be uh you know essential to
our success
what i'm asking is the scale of what the
cdc is recommending in terms of the
changes some schools would have to make
whether it's through their hvac systems
or their spacing or as you know to hire
bus drivers teachers that would take
time
it takes time to get money out the door
how does that
impact the first hundred days it impacts
it because it means
there's an urgency to getting this money
through uh and to ensuring that
that schools have the ability to plan
ahead some of these schools and
obviously i'm not speaking to any
particular district but broadly speaking
you know they have funding that they can
front load right but they need to know
their security of funding that is ahead
and so this funding is essential to
being able to provide the necessary
resources to
many schools across the country that
want to implement
these mitigation measures take the steps
work with their local
school districts and school boards to do
it but don't have the resources to
uh effectively do it and again as soon
as our education secretary is sworn in
uh this is going to be his number one
priority good just go ahead
really quick sure the president
mentioned it didn't seem like he was
endorsing it just that he mentioned that
the idea of summer school uh is that
something he would like
everything on summer sports the dream
your kids probably want summer
um but is that something he would like
to see i know it's in the discussion and
i know it's up to school districts and
is that something he'd like to do if
schools are able to reopen to have full
semesters for summer school
well it is something that is an option
and uh you know our department of
education is also undergoing
a study to determine the impact of
kovid on kids and schools and what is
the impact
of doing remote learning what's the
impact of not being in school with your
teacher and
from that you know they'll be able to
work with school districts on what's
going to work best to address
the challenges and needs that they're
finding through that study
but this funding that is in the american
rescue plan can be used for a range of
purposes and we've talked about a lot of
them
bus drivers uh hiring of temporary
teachers
uh you know ppe or other equipment
but also can be used for tutoring or
summer school in cases where that would
be an appropriate step and
it's really going to be up to the school
districts to determine that
you've said that you've said that the
president's preference is that states
prioritize
teachers this is a vaccine that's being
provided for free
to the states by the federal government
can't you mandate
that states prioritize teachers
we can provide federal guidelines which
is exactly what we've done
but we work in close partnership and
coordination with states to
make recommendations on the
prioritization and they implement
of course the the power of the
presidency and the power of the vice
presidency is certainly conveying what
their
preference is which they have both done
over the last 24 hours but
uh that's not how the process has worked
and i don't anticipate it would be
that's how it worked moving forward
got it and then the president said
yesterday his goal is to have the
majority of k-8 schools
open five days a week by day 100 what
about high schools what's the goal for
them
i'm not going to set new goals here
other than to say that the president
wants
students to be in school learning with
their teachers
five days a week and he wants that to
happen as quickly as possible
and do it safely and he's obviously said
he wants that to happen
in the first hundred days it is harder
and we saw this in the cdc guidelines
but also from many of our health experts
uh because of social distancing
it is more challenging with older
students than it is with younger
students and that is of course it has to
be a factor and
something that i'm sure school districts
will consider they're also suffering
more aren't they well again there's a
study that our department of education
is undergoing uh to provide require data
to
make a determination about
recommendations on how to address the
impacts um
we'll let them speak to that but i think
we can all see anecdotally of course
what the impact is on older students
we want students to be back in the
classroom but we want to do it safely
and and the president's committed to
doing that and then finally you said
previously that the goal was to have the
majority of k-8 schools open
at least one day a week in the first 100
days last night president biden called
that a mistake
in communications who wants them open
five days a week
so can you clarify what is the
administration's goal for reopening k-8
schools in the first 100 years
i'm not going to take it personally that
you don't hang on every word that i say
in here
i did say last thursday that the
president will not rest until every
school is open five days a week that is
our goal
that is what we want to achieve but we
are going to we look forward to seeing
and hearing the cdc guidelines to gain a
better understanding of what steps that
will entail or should entail
i also said i can assure any parent
listening that is objective his
commitment is to ensure schools are open
five days a week
so i think we've been consistent for the
last several days and certainly when i
initially said one day a week it was our
it was our floor it was not our ceiling
but
uh without a doubt the president wants
schools to open five days a week wants
students to be in the classroom
wants to do that safely we now have some
guidelines from the cdc with several
mitigation steps
uh we'll have to work we need funding to
do that that is a pivotal piece of it
many school districts need funding they
don't have it
and also we need our secretary of
education in place to
work to implement thank you sure go
ahead another follow-up on last night
the president said pretty clearly
that he doesn't think he has the
authority to cancel fifty thousand
dollars in
student loan debt today senator schumer
and warren
said in a statement that they were told
the administration is still working
on figuring out if it has the authority
so if your lawyers would determine that
canceling this is legal
would the president go ahead with this
and if not why not
well first on last night last night's
town hall for those who didn't see the
whole thing
uh he was reiterating his previously
stated position which is he doesn't
favor fifty thousand dollars in student
loan relief without limitation and he
used some examples of
the types of schools or when it should
be reimbursed or
refunded he said previously that relief
above 10
000 should be targeted based on the
borrower's income based on the kind of
debt in question
public schools versus private schools
graduate schools versus undergraduate
obviously there's a lot of
considerations
at play what the president has told
senator schumer and warren
is that once his team is in place at the
justice department and they are not
of course they're they're not confirmed
at this point he will ask them to
conduct a
legal review of his authority to act by
executive action in conjunction with a
policy review from his domestic
policy council on his executive on how
executive action debt relief
if any should be targeted so obviously
that's a review that would need to take
place there's a legal consideration
there as i think
everybody agrees there's a policy
consideration
and once that's concluded he'll decide
ruled it out if all of these ifs and
buts are still
in place and obviously you need your
team in place and the review to take
place
that's right there needs to be a team at
the justice department to make a
recommendation on his legal authority
uh and obviously the domestic policy
team is in place but they would be a
part of that conversation
certainly as well and in the meantime if
congress moves forward and
sends him a package that uh you know
provides ten thousand dollars of student
debt relief he'd he'd be
eager to sign that uh so there are
several lovers here and he's
he's um looking forward to that process
moving forward
um go ahead oh you go ahead go ahead
yeah
sorry i know it's like my point is kind
of all over the place um the president
during the
campaign supported the study
corporations the committee to study
reparations there was a house
judiciary committee hearing today um
does the president support the
legislation he stopped short of saying
that during the campaign
would he sign that if it came to his
desk well he supported a study of
reparations which i believe is what's
being
discussed and studying the continuing
impacts of slavery which is being
discussed in this uh
hearing on h.r 40 i believe it is and he
continues to demonstrate his commitment
to take
comprehensive action to address the
systemic racism that persists today
obviously that is having that study is a
part of that but
he has signed an executive order on his
first day uh which would begin
to deliver on his commitment to having
an across
government uh approach to addressing uh
racial inequality and
and making sure equity is a part of his
entire policy agenda
but he certainly would support a study
of reparations and
we understand understands that we don't
need a study to take
right now in systemic racism so he wants
to take action
government in the meantime support the
bill because you're talking about the
state but if the bill until it's
destroyed
well it's working its way through
congress he'd certainly support a study
but
we'll see what happens through the
legislative process
um quite a few executive actions
why not on this issue create a
commission in my executive order
he actually signed a number of acton's
equity in on his first day or his first
couple days in office
because he felt it was essential to send
the message to the american people and
the world that
uh having an across government approach
ensuring that equities
is a central part of his policy agenda
uh
was you know not just a a single a
singular issue but something that would
be a part of every policy issue
he approaches whether it's healthcare
whether it's economic inequality
a range of issues that's his approach
and how he's trying to
um you know change address the root
causes of racism in our country today
but he doesn't support reparations
executables
again he well it would be up to him it's
a you know he he has executive order
authority he would
certainly support uh a study um and
we'll see where congress moves on that
issue
go ahead um just again uh you know
you're getting a lot of follow-ups
from last night and one more um the
present's cool i welcome it
uh the president spoke about uh minimum
wage last night
and reiterated his support for uh 15 an
hour
and at the same time uh you know he also
tried to explain sort of
a gradual rollout and he spoke about 12
13.
we appreciate the clarification your
office put out this morning about
uh about what that would look like i'm
just trying to get a
better understanding of whether the
white house will still insist that
fifteen dollars go
into the into the bill uh the covet uh
relief bill
now and and if it if that is not
happening what is the
path forward is it the house legislation
uh talking about
uh you know 15 by october 2025 is that
what the white house will support if
this doesn't happen
what is it looking like well uh we're in
the middle of the legislative process
for the american rescue plan
and we fully recognize as does the
president having served in the senate
for 36 years that
his bill that he proposed that included
a 15 minimum wage increase included many
other key components
may not look exactly the same on the
other end when it comes out of the
sausage making machine
but he put it in there the uh raise of
the minimum wage because he
it feels it's important it's a priority
and that uh
men and women who are working hard who
are
living on you know making honest living
shouldn't be living at the poverty level
we will let that process see itself
through it's not even to the senate yet
um and it will move its way through the
senate process and
hopefully soon but i'm not going to get
ahead of the process in congress so
you're still optimistic jen that
15 will make it um into this package and
will become
a reality we'll see uh it's up to
members of congress to determine
uh what the final package looks like
it's a priority to the president that's
why he put it in the package
but he also and i appreciate you
referencing uh uh
you know the the sorry the the ex
that we're exactly i just like stumbled
over 100 words i appreciate you
referencing that
uh when he was asked this question last
night it was by a small business owner
who was concerned
uh that immediately he would or this is
what the president's takeaway was
that immediately he would be in a place
where he had to pay his workers
15 an hour next month or soon
uh and the president was explaining to
him that this would be uh
you know progressive increase right and
that's something that senator sanders
supports as well so he was explaining it
would go to 12 then it would go to 13 it
would be over a series of time over a
couple of years
so that was how he was explaining it but
again the process is ongoing
we look forward to it moving forward
rapidly and we'll see what comes out on
the other side so he definitely supports
even a gradual rollout
as as an option on the table oh
absolutely he supports a gradual
increase that it wouldn't be an
immediate and as the senator sanders and
as do many advocates for increasing the
minimum wage
absolutely go ahead i wanted to ask one
a point of clarification on the
summer school question um are you saying
that there would be an additional
funding stream for schools that wanted
to go in that direction that would be
part of the larger covenant
it's part of the larger it's an option
in the school funding that's in the
covid package
beyond that is the department of
education going to make an ultimate
recommendation on how districts should
handle the question of
holding in-person summer education for
students who have been out of the
classroom for so long
i'm sure that's something they'll look
at and i think what they're eager to
have access to
is this data on what the impact has been
of
students being out of school students
learning remotely hybrid learning
we don't know there's not really a big
precedent for this and they want to be
able to look at that data
and of course secretary cardona as a
former educator himself i guess once an
educator always an educator
uh will be leading that effort and
working with school districts let me ask
one more
on a different topic just because it's
an issue that's come up in congress it's
being
talked about in dc is does the president
given his relationship with the senate
have a view on permanent fencing around
the u.s capitol it's likely something
that if it were to happen would be an
appropriation that the president would
have to sign
it it's really up to congress to
determine uh
what measures need to be taken and i'm
sure they're working with their own
uh the capitol police and others to make
that determination but we don't have any
further comment from here or evaluation
um go ahead thanks jen um a top cdc
official and
uh transportation secretary buddha judge
bulls
in recent weeks that topic testing for
domestic flights
was under consideration and i know you
said last week that those reports were
inaccurate
um and the cdc cdc issued a statement
saying
it's not recommending it but i guess why
is
domestic testing no longer on the table
at a time when
countries like canada are significant
increasing coveted travel restrictions
and did the white house have a
conversation with the cdc
about the proposal given the pressure
coming from the airline industry
no there's a policy process for every
consideration right and obviously we
have said we will
lead with the guidance of health and
science experts and as you noted the cdc
put out a statement
on this last week uh there are steps
that we have put in place uh as you may
uh be familiar with including mandatory
masking on flights which
our health experts feel is a is an
effective
uh step that that should be taken on
airlines
uh and also we've limited uh restricted
travel
from uh in international travel uh but
that's not a step that
uh was uh determined uh was essential to
be made um so we
will follow the guidelines uh go ahead
thanks um i want to get back to the
texas crisis
so about a decade ago federal regulators
suggested they urge texas
to weatherize its power grid
that largely did not happen or it
certainly didn't happen enough
uh and of course it was only a
suggestion because texas is not part of
the national grid
um you may have seen that rick perry the
former energy secretary and governor of
texas
had uh has said today that uh texans
would rather
endure days of blackouts than submit to
federal regulation
is the president willing to leave 30
million texans off of the national grid
there's a lot packed into that question
uh i will i will do my best to
answer it um let me first say that um
uh building resilient and sustainable
infrastructure
that can withstand extreme weather and a
changing climate will play an integral
role in creating
millions to clean the economy and
meeting
the president's goal of reaching a net
zero emissions future by
2050 and also will be beneficial
in future storms i will say that there
has been some
inaccurate accusations out there i'm not
sure if former
secretary uh perry made these but uh
that it was the fi that that suggested
um
that uh renewables caused failures um
in texas's power grid and actually
numerous reports have actually shown the
contrary
that it was failures in coal and natural
gas that contributed to the state's
power shortages
and officials at the electric
reliability council of texas
which operates the state's power grid
have gone so far as to say that failures
in wind and solar were the least
significant factors
in the blackouts i know that wasn't
exactly your question but i just wanted
to convey that since there's been a lot
of confusion about it
uh beyond that about the power grid i
would certainly send you to the
department of energy for any further
uh comment on that particular line of
questioning um also on the crisis a lot
of texans are concerned
that their homeowners insurance is not
going to cover
for instance pipes that burst um i
some policies might cover that some
might not will fema
make people hold for that kind of damage
i would i would certainly send you to
fema they obviously as i noted at the
top are very involved in providing
generators water steps
but in any crisis in the recovery of it
there are typically many agencies
involved
fema's a coordinating body as you all
know but just for others
uh but i would send you to them for any
uh other update on that
a quick question from this morning the
president received ashes for ash
wednesday
um what if anything is he giving up for
lent
oh what a good question i should have
asked him that question today
um i i will have to follow up with you
on that particular question i don't know
sometimes people don't give something up
sometimes they do something good
so it could be either option but i will
see if i can get more information i'm
sorry i have a
question from outside the room sure
there's a move apparently
to rename the las vegas airport or harry
reid
any idea if the president would suggest
would support that i have not spoken
with him about that
i know obviously he has a great deal of
respect for senator reid they worked
together for many years he was
an incredibly important partner during
the obama biden administration to the
then vice president um but in terms of
the renaming of airports i believe
that's congress to determine that but i
will
i will see if the president has any
further comment on it he has of course a
big harry reid fan go ahead
thanks jen i have a couple different
questions first of all is the president
going to release a statement or say
something about rush limbaugh
i know obviously the news just came out
in about the last hour before i had come
out
um i can say i'm not sure if we'll
release a statement from the president
he has spoken to
in the past uh to uh to rush limbaugh's
sickness and illness at the time and
certainly
um you know he his condolences go out to
the family and the friends
uh of rush limbaugh who have of course
have lost
him today but i don't know that i
anticipate a statement from the
president but i can certainly
pass on his uh condolences and
expression of support for the family
and on a different topic is the
administration going to get involved in
the case of
princess latifah the daughter of the
dubai ruler who has released videos
claiming to be held hostage
i'm happy to follow up with our national
security team on that particular
question as well go ahead in the back
thanks jen i want to ask you about the
the meeting that's going to take place
in a little bit with the labor leaders
richard trumka head of the afl-cio has
said in the past that he believes the
president learned a lesson with his
keystone decision that if you're going
to make a
decision in which jobs are lost you
should have a specific simultaneous
announcement
in which there are jobs added trump just
said quote
i wish he hadn't speaking of the
president done that on the first day
because the laborers
laborers international was right the
labor international has said a thousand
jobs for loss
i'm wondering is the president going to
bring this issue
up when he meets with the labor leaders
did the president
learn any lesson as richard trumka
suggested and is he open to potentially
uh looking at this decision once again
from from another angle
well this is not the first time this has
happened in here where there's been
about
half of richard trumka's statement or
comment in that particular interview
shared and not the full context
and the other context i unfortunately
don't have it in front of me
is about his belief that the president
is committed to
creating good paying union jobs uh and
that is certainly what will be central
to the discussion the president has with
union leaders today uh including uh his
desire to
uh create good clean energy
union uh good paying union jobs uh and
that
he believes that those two uh can
simultaneously happen
uh he when he put out his clean energy
plan
last year he had union leaders and
environmentalists at the same table
agreeing to the path forward uh and he
has a
uh extensive record on this particular
issue i will say since you gave me the
opportunity
uh a clean uh prior to kovit 19
the bureau of labor and statistics
reported that two of the fastest growing
jobs were in the wind turbine and solar
industries and that's just the start
the national academies of sciences
reported last week that a transition to
a net zero emissions economy could grow
millions of jobs
over the next decade and our plan the
president's plan which we'll talk about
today will make
historic investments in infrastructure
in the auto industry and transit in
power
and also addressing the climate crisis
head on i'm sure he'll talk about that
with the union leaders today can i ask
you about other future plans as well
you said yesterday uh quote we haven't
yet determined what the next priority
forward would be but he meaning the
president is engaging with this policy
team
earlier this month when the president
met the oval with house democrats
he said quote i can hardly wait to sit
down with peter defazio to work on
infrastructure
this is the next big piece so i'm
wondering he is excited about
infrastructure and i'm sure he will be
talking about it today
is it indeed the next big piece or is
the administration trying to figure out
what the next big
piece will be well first i will say uh
our focus right now and the president's
focus is
american rescue plan and moving that
doing everything he can
to move that through congress to
communicate with the american public
to convey why there's money needed for
to reopen schools to get shots and arms
to get direct checks out to the american
people we will i would not expect him to
lay out
next pieces of his agenda until that
package is through and signed
and that relief is going out to the
public in the interim period
he's going to consult with a range of
stakeholders labor leaders today
members of congress and senate leaders
last week he had a discussion with the
american public on television during a
town hall last night
to determine what the next steps look
like infrastructure is certainly
an issue he's had a long passion for he
does believe it creates
good paying union jobs he thinks they
can be done as clean energy jobs uh but
uh we're going to focus our efforts uh
at this point in time on the american
rescue plan
if i made one more um the vice president
said
um speaking of of vaccines and
distribution coveted
et cetera she said quote in many ways we
are starting from scratch on something
that's been raging for almost a year
however
dr fauci has recently said quote we're
not starting from scratch because there
is activity going on
in the distribution and even today your
administration said that there would be
the number was 892
000 doses that were administered in the
final week before the president took
over um
so is that the best message to say that
this administration
started from scratch when there were
indeed doses going out the door and
folks like dr fauci say that's that's
not the case well
i i don't think and most governors or
most of the american people
would tell you that they think it was
handled effectively and efficiently by
the prior administration
uh given we are we are when when the
president came in and the vice president
came in
there were not enough vaccines there
were not enough vaccinators there were
not enough vaccine vaccination locations
they've taken significant steps to
address all of those issues
yes in the week prior to the president
taking office
there were about 800 to 900 000 as you
said
doses doing uh being given a day the on
the average was about 400 to 500 000
prior to that
last week the average was 1.7 million a
day so
there are significant steps that have
been taken what they were conveying
was that uh we did not have a
comprehensive plan there were not enough
vaccines there was not enough
coordination
with governors and local officials and
there were not enough places where
people could get the vaccine
and now we're working to address that
and it was important for the vice
president to convey that because the
american people need to know what we're
digging out of
uh and that was why she said it go ahead
oh let me go to the back because he
hasn't had a question down
can you question on tokyo games
so presidents say any decision must be
based on
science but i'd like to know how soon
he expects to see a final decision if
there'll be any tokyo begins
is he confident that we have saved
olympic games in tokyo
i just don't have an update i understand
question lots of focus and interest on
the olympics but i don't have any update
from here
he will participate in the g7 uh meeting
this coming friday
i understand he'll focus on pandemic
economic and china
but should we expect to be more
discussions such as
tokyo some olympic games we'll see i'm
sure there'll be a range of issues that
are raised by the members of the g7 and
it's important opportunity to have a
conversation and obviously he'll
be delivering remarks i think we'll be
previewing his remarks
which will give him a little bit more
time to work on since he was traveling
yesterday
uh later probably tomorrow night in
advance of friday and there'll be more
of an overview of what
you should expect him to talk about go
ahead yes i
just had a point of clarification on
student loans um as i understood it last
night at the town hall president biden
said he was prepared to write off ten
thousand dollars in loans
but not fifty thousand dollars because
he doesn't think he has the authority
and you said that that legal review
still has to take place but is the door
for the president himself is the door to
50 000
essentially closed at this point the the
president has previously stated that he
does not favor
50 000 in student loan relief without
limitation
and some of what he talked about last
night much more extensively than what
i'm about to say
but is that uh you know there are a lot
of factors public schools versus private
schools graduate schools versus
undergraduate schools uh and he also
believes that relief above
he continues to believe that relief
above ten thousand dollars should be
targeted
and ten thousand dollars he's conveyed
because there's been proposals in
congress as you probably know
that he'd be eager to sign that bill
that congress can pass
but yes there's a legal review there's
going to be a review by our domestic
policy team
uh uh that to consider all of these
options uh and
we'll wait for that conclusion before a
final decision is made
gotcha and then and then one other
question just building off of the
shorter
questions about texas does the white
house believe that more
should have happened earlier to better
prepare texas
power grids and water systems for
climate change
um and what does the white house believe
needs to happen there and in other
states going forward and
does the kind of crisis we're seeing
right now make any of those things
more urgent it's a really important
question i think our focus though right
now
is on providing relief to the emergency
situation that we're seeing in texas and
in surrounding states i'm sure there'll
be
time to look back and evaluate uh what
better preparations if better
preparation should have been done
could be could have been made but at
this point in time we're just focused on
getting relief to the people in the
state and the surrounding states i
should say
great question on going back to the five
days
of sure again at the end of the day
unions uh local school officials
governors
will have the ultimate say on this is
the president and
the end of the day is he setting a goal
um
that can't that he can't meet and that
is ultimately not his to me
well you're right in the sense then this
kind of goes back to
one of nancy's earlier questions right
this is going to be up to local schools
and school districts
however what has been lacking is clear
federal guidelines
based on science done by health experts
to
give schools a better understanding or a
better road map
for what mitigation steps they can take
to ensure their teachers their students
their community can return safely that
was what was
announced by the cdc of course on friday
the role that the president can play i'm
not the president i work
i'm speaking for him the role the
president can play
is to work with congress to get the
necessary funding
that is the role he can really play that
is why his focus is on
the american rescue plan working with
congress the role the federal government
can play
is from of course not just providing the
cdc guidelines from the cdc director and
their team
but also having our department of
education work with schools
on figuring out you know how to apply
the uh the review or the research that
is currently underway
and how to apply the mitigation steps
that will be secretary cardona's
first priority when he takes office but
it will be up to the local school
districts to determine the
implementation of the mitigation steps
thanks jim thank you everyone thank you
you